more spider-man news today got trailer 2
and a villain update supposedly let's
see what's going on today we were going
to cover cowboy bebop this morning but
apparently that's coming out this
afternoon don't worry we'll still cover
that netflix trailer even though they
always partially block him copyright
claim us but it won't just be spider-man
today it's gonna be spider-man in the
morning and then cowboy bebop
roughly around four to five p.m pacific
standard time according to the internet
let's see what's going on here people
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some exciting and also
some not so exciting news about
spider-man no way home depending on how
you view this new information about the
film rare thing to hear you say a rather
odd surprise but i'll let you be the
judge of whether or not you think this
is good or bad news we have a trailer
update that is good news and then we
have some news about the sinister six or
i should say the sinister five as
there's been a new report on
this could be in spider-man no way home
i know everybody wants to know about
that trailer especially after yesterday
there was a lot of conflicting reports
yesterday and at some point there were
rumors going around that the second
trailer wasn't even done and that it had
some type of problem and that it
probably wasn't going to be done anytime
soon or before the eternals however it
seems like this was quickly proven wrong
and in fact the opposite was true the
spider-man noah home second official
trailer is actually done we've learned
this because the new government website
where ads and trailers get raided
approve the second spider-man no way
home trailer we even have a screenshot
of this so it is indeed done because how
can you approve something that's not
done so since it's completed and
approved in korea we can assume that
it's completed everywhere and although
we don't have a specific trailer date
right now insiders say that it's
probably coming within the next two
weeks and i've also heard that we should
be getting it before november 15th i
find it so fascinating i understood for
the first trailer how we were just
demanding through the roof non-stop like
when's that trailer coming it's been
forever we've been hearing about this
movie for so long i don't know why i'm a
little bit more a lot more patient the
second time around because i'm like well
the movie's coming out soon so the
trailer's bound to come at some point
soon we don't even have a poster yet but
already it's begun just in a much
shorter time frame of like the fake
leaks the fake reports the news that is
sending everyone into this anxiety
frenzy it's supposed to come out monday
and i'm just like huh mom
i'll just wait
oh wait i'll wait to hear i'm of course
i'm excited for it and of course i'm
expecting to see some toby and andrew in
there let's chill a little bit but the
same time it's a lot of fun so keep
doing what you're doing and i personally
think that it's probably going to come
the tuesday after
eternals releases that's just my current
prediction i could be wrong i'm not
married to this prediction that's just
when i think it'll come but hey the hype
is huge probably bigger than endgame so
whatever they're doing it's working but
they obviously know that fans are
getting a little upset that we haven't
seen that full trailer yet now the
second piece of news that we have today
is about the sinister six or i should
say the villains of the film and this
report is coming from my buddies over on
twitter big screen leaks i've talked to
yourselves i know that they are reliable
and yesterday the people i talked about
by the way rhino isn't in spiderman no
way home he is frequently talked about
and is the butt of many jokes but he's
not in the film rhino i think is a rumor
that got thrown out as leaks and there
were many many fake photos of rhino and
all of this eventually led to everybody
just kind of saying that he was in the
movie and it did make sense and i even
thought he was going to be in the movie
as well but according to bsl he is not
going to be in the movie however he is
going to be talked about which may have
been where all the confusion might have
come from but if you're wondering who
the sixth villain actually is going to
be according to there's no sixth villain
no one that's right according to them
it's us no sixth villain it's just going
to be a sinister five now this is a
rather odd decision you have five
villains why not go for one more to make
it the sinister six and have that movie
but perhaps this really isn't a sinister
six movie you know i'm not surprised by
this at all there's not one part of me
that's actually surprised by this if
anything if there was to be a six member
i would like it to be if someone from
holland's universe preferably mysterio
obviously there still could be a six
member you know these are just leaks and
scoops and whatever but none of this is
confirmed so there still could be a six
member but i firmly believe sony is
actually gearing up to do a sinister six
film again i think that didn't pan out
last time the one withdrew goddard and i
firmly believe that that is the next
step mark my words i've just marked my
words on this all right remember this
moment in time if you made us this point
in the video somewhere down the road
we're going to hear an announcement
about a sinister six movie so right now
this is the lead up to it helps keep it
focused there still might be a six
member but if there's not i guarantee
you they're gonna make a sinister six
film this one that's gonna be the
central focus of it maybe in title maybe
it's a venom or spider-man movie but for
sure there will be an announcement for
it just you wait and see really isn't a
sinister six movie perhaps it's just a
multiversal movie and we just happen to
have other villains coming from other
universes and other spiderman it does
kind of seem like a missed opportunity
but you never really know what sony has
up their sleeve you never really know
what their plans are for their own sony
universe and the mcu moving forward we
know that tom holland is probably going
to be coming back a spider-man and you
have to wonder well what's next if you
have the spider-verse the other two
spider-man and all of these other
villains coming back how do you top that
well we know venom is eventually going
to be coming and facing off against
spider-man and perhaps we will get a
true spider-man and the sinister six
film and i think some people really like
this but i think a lot of people don't
like it as well because we were just one
villain away from having the entire
sinister six but i know some people
would like to be messing with the stuff
tom holland just him alone going up
against the sinister six him doing it by
himself some people kind of complained
that we never really get our spider-man
on his own kind of having to fend for
himself he was taken under the wing of
tony stark now he's being taken under
the wing kind of of doctor strange and
now he's being taken out of the wing of
mark wahlberg yeah
[ __ ] that's right man spider-man no
more mentors now he's being taken under
the wing kind of of doctor strange and
then the other two spider-man when is he
going to be on his own and it is
possible that that's what sony might
have up their sleeve are spider-man
versus a sinister six perhaps one that
they've already established in the mcu
vulture scorpion chameleon perhaps
mysterio is still alive so there are
villains that could still be the
sinister six that our spider-man could
go up against sounds way better we don't
have that much left
until we see the actual film only about
a month and a half now and it's still
very weird that we don't have that
trailer yet but hopefully that is coming
soon as well in the meantime let me know
what you think about this very very
interesting news of there only being
five villains in spider-man no way home
leave your thoughts down below in the
comments don't forget to like this video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram twitter and tick tock and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof i'd prefer that if they
finally did a sinister sex movie with
spider-man that it's tom holland's
personal set of villains they got people
to mine from we'd hear kingpins coming
back in hawkeye he could show up in
spider-man so i personally think that
would be way more interesting and a more
satisfying sinister six uh because
that's what the sinister six ought to be
is not three spider-man versing six
villains should be one spider-man
version six villains and if you have
already three spider-man versus five
villains you get that cake and you are
able to eat it two minus one villain so
i feel like either way you're getting
all the sinister action you might want
yeah exactly exactly guys subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell hit that like button and hey catch
you guys with cowboy